ein amerikaner hat wirklich
unglaubliches erlebt und überlebt er
wurde sieben mal vom blitz getroffen
wie und wo er verletzt wurde jetzt in
diesem video und noch mehr ziemlich
vertrackt über blitze lieben dank für
euren kult vorschlag bei whatsapp und
herzlich willkommen bei klicks um
science-fiction gibt täglich
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
unser passt kein video mehr okay let's
go herzlich willkommen erst perfekt so
entstehen witze weltweit gibt es jeden
tag zwischen 10 und 30 millionen blitze
umgerechnet also 100 blitze pro sekunde
davon schlagen allerdings nur etwa zehn
prozent in den erdboden ein unglaubliche
200.000 blitze lassen sich an starken
gewitter tagen an deutschlands himmel
zählen meistens in den monaten mai bis
september
denn dann treten luftmassen aufeinander
die sehr unterschiedliche temperaturen
aufweisen
in der gewitterwolke bewegen sich die
eis und wasser teilchen auf und ab und
die natürliche luft elektrizität wird
polarisiert die positive elektrische
ladung befindet sich zunehmend im oberen
teil der wolke
die negative ladung an ihrer unterseite
dieses elektrische spannungsfeld wird
immer größer und entlädt sich
schließlich ja vergleichbar mit einem
kurzschluss der blitz wandert dann im
zickzack richtung boden kilometer weit
dann kommen ihnen fang ladung entgegen
die ihn in eine bestimmte richtung
lenken beispielsweise von einem hohen
turm oder einer stromleitung beim
einschlag entlädt sich ein gewaltiger
strom und die luft wird auf 30.000 grad
celsius selbst zweiter effekt nicht nur
auf der erde gibt es blitze nicht nur
auf der erde sondern auch auf anderen
planeten wie dem jupiter und dem saturn
gibt es blitze möglicherweise auch auf
neptun venus und uranus die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass der
jeweilige planet eine dichte atmosphäre
hat schon in den 70er jahren
registrierten instrumente der volta
raumsonden blitze beim jupiter also
elektromagnetische strahlung in
kilohertz frequenzbereich ähnlich wie
bei uns auf der erde und auch ansonsten
sind sie den irdischen blitzen ähnlicher
als gedacht später gab es dann von der
raumsonde galileo bilder von jupiter
blitzen die tausendfach stärker sein
könnten als die auf der erde zudem
kommen sie dort weitaus häufiger vor wie
ein forschungsteam erst in diesem jahr
entdeckte im durchschnitt gibt es auf
dem jupiter auf jedem quadratkilometer
bis zu 30 blitze auf der erde sind es
nur 6 im jahr auch die saturn witze sind
wohl nicht ohne das legen daten nahe die
die raumsonde cassini empfang hatte
demnach könnten die blitze dort bürger
millionenfach stärker sein als auf der
erde
dritter fact es gibt verschiedene arten
von blitzen es gibt tatsächlich nicht
nur den einen blitz sondern verschiedene
blitz arten unterschieden werden sie zum
einen nach der richtung des light straße
und danach welche polarität die zur erde
transportierte ladung hat der blitz der
am häufigsten vorkommt ist der wolke
erde blitz etwa 90 prozent der blitzer
auf der erde gehören in diese kategorie
hier gehen die verästelungen des leids
stress von der wolke aus der leitstrahl
wandert von der wolke aus auf den
erdboden und trifft dort die fangen
ladung je nachdem wie die polarität des
streits ist wird er dann entweder
positiver wolke erde blitz genannt oder
negativer wolke erde blitz für perfekt
diese blitz mythen sind totaler unsinn
wenn blitze am himmel zucken sollte man
weder eichen noch buchen bäuml als
schutz aussuchen der alte spruch
bereichen sollst du weichen buchen dort
zu suchen wird also in die tonne
denn bäume sind gewöhnlich hoch und
blitze suchen sich gerne hohe objekte
also diese einladung dabei ist es ihnen
komplett egal um welche baumart es sich
dort gerade handelt auch der rat sich
auf einem freien feld flach hinzulegen
ist nicht der ultimative tipp besser in
eine mulde oder einen graben hocken die
füße dicht beieinander halten und die
beine mit den armen umfassen
doch bei gewitter mit blitz muss man
nicht nur auch noch das handy
ausschalten und schmuck braucht er auch
nicht auszuziehen denn beides zieht die
blitze nicht an
regenschirme macht er dagegen besser zu
wenn er unterwegs sagt schnell zum auto
zurück denn der bildet einen sogenannten
faradayschen käfig und leitet den blitze
außenrum ab cabrios oder autos mit viel
kunststoff dagegen sind im vergleich
dazu nicht
fünfter fängt das ist zu tun wenn dich
der blitz trifft oder jemanden in seiner
nähe
nach schätzung von experten und
expertinnen passierte sehr selten dass
ein mensch in deutschland von einem
blitz getroffen wird zwischen 50 und 100
fälle gibt es wohl pro jahr in den usa
sind es 300 menschen die pro jahr vom
blitz getroffen werden einer von zehn
menschen stirbt an den folgen des
blitzeinschlages rekordhalter ist ein
amerikanischer rangers element ist laut
dem guinness buch der rekorde
unglaubliche sieben mal von einem blitz
getroffen worden und hat überlebt
verloren hat er allerdings beim ersten
mal den nagel des großen zehs beim
zweiten mal eine augenbraue
dann wurde seine linke schulter verletzt
dann verschmutzen die kopf und bein
paare und beim sechsten mal gelang der
blitz in den knöchel und beim siebten
und vorletzten mal verbrannte sein
oberkörper also verbrennungen außerhalb
am schlimmsten und oft auch tätig sind
die direkten witz anschlage in den
körper also wenn der blitz in den kopf
einschlägt und dann durch den gesamten
körper zieht dann wird das elektrische
leitungssystem des herzens durcheinander
gebracht und es kommt zu
herzrhythmusstörungen auch die
nervenzellen werden durch den
elektrischen schlag angegriffen und der
atem setzt aus das kann dann auch zum
kreislaufstillstand führen häufiger aber
sind indirekt treffer wenn es
beispielsweise in einen mast ein steckt
und sich die elektrizität über dem boden
ausbreitet auf dem sich menschen
befinden wenn jemand in eurer nähe vom
blitz getroffen wird leistet unbedingt
erste hilfe und ruft den notarzt den
studien besagen dass blitz opfer große
chancen haben sich wieder vom kreislauf
stillstand zu erholen
denn der strom zieht zwar heftig durch
den körper allerdings nur kurz doch ein
blitzschlag in die menschen körper kann
auch noch weitere langfristige schäden
mit sich ziehen
zudem hinterlassen blitze oft auch
sichtbare spuren wie beispielsweise ein
bestimmtes muster in der haut was sich
ein brennt wie ein tattoo quasi ok eine
schmerzhafte methode ein tattoo zu
bekommen ja wenn ihr dieses video
spannend gefunden habt dann endet meine
telefonnummer whatsapp dann bekommt ihr
täglich vor allen anderen den link zum
video von mir persönlich geschickt und
ein kleines geschenk zur begrüßung
einfach hier draufklicken und darunter
auch draufklicken außergewöhnlicher
weißer zwerg schießt energetische blitze
eine ganz andere form von blick
bis dann bleibt dran